as [ __ ] ass has bad words hey wait is
the pen drop is that is that like like
when a comedian drops the mic is that
like the equivalent when like for a
writer the far less dramatic you just
like write something and drop your pen
like you think Sean does a typewriter
drop like the murder she read like to
chicken that year that's a perfect place
to start hello everybody welcome to the
middlemost podcast and we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalist and we're gonna talk
about tribes we're gonna talk about
picking sides whose side are you on Ryan
I'm on your side Josh that's the right
ass as long as you're on my side we're
talk about finding common ground with
people who have different beliefs with
today's guest my friend comedian and
political podcaster Jamie kill Steen is
here Jamie thank you for being here hi
everybody I'm so excited about this
awesome so Jamie we we met on Twitter
like I've got all good relationships yep
it will at least in the 21st century
that's where all good relationships I've
met more awesome people on Twitter than
anywhere else
I hate Twitter and social media with all
of my being and like have told agents
when they were like what's your going in
in life and like in Hollywood I'm like
my goal is to get famous enough to get
off social media forever which agents
don't want to hear so don't do that but
at the same time I have met like my best
friends through Twitter yeah if there's
someone you admire you can reach out and
like become homies it's amazing yes
today we're gonna talk about finding
common ground and I think one of the
problems with social media is people are
just lobbing grenades at each other
because like oh we don't have common
ground I'm gonna have to destroy you if
I disagree with you and we want to do
the opposite today we want to help
people find some common ground so we've
got some questions here today let's
start with Morgan in Salt Lake City Utah
right now I'm struggling with a tiny
predicament I hate snow
and I have been in Salt Lake City in my
entire life I'm 24 years old
that's 24 years of snow and I recently
went to Phoenix and fell in love with
the city brought my boyfriend with me
and he was kind of indifferent and then
struggling because I don't like leave
him behind to start over but I don't
know how to handle the snow another year
another winter and I just can't seem to
get him on board with the Arizona idea
so how do you handle a scenario where
you're ready to like jump in both feet
and your partner is hesitant minimize
them next question I have so many
thoughts on this I feel like there's got
to be I mean I would love to ask her how
the relationship is otherwise because
she's sort of sounded ready to go when
she was like man I hate the snow I'm
like ready to leave like her voice
dropped and a kind of whisper and I feel
like if you're that willing to leave
your boyfriend or your partner behind
over like the weather there may be
something else to examine there I think
that I am moving to Arizona tomorrow I
have only lived in New York City and Los
Angeles because of my career ever since
I started visiting Arizona much like her
something magical has happened I don't
honk my horn I'm not on my phone as much
I'm not driving as fast I'm not
constantly feeling judged and the
weather I get to in New York I was I
mean New York's miserable besides the
weather New York when I moved to LA and
people were like so mean about LA like
all my New York friends are like yeah
they're just fake happy and then I move
out here and I'm like no they're happy
happy because it's amazing and because
it's sunny and cuz everyone's positive
and because you know a homeless guy
didn't take a [ __ ] in your backpack on
the subway and then you get back to your
apartment and one of your 15 mean
roommates took a [ __ ] in your other
backpack like it is I am I was so happy
to be here
LA was my upgrade from New York and
saved me from legit depression and
Arizona is kind of my upgrade from LA or
my minimizing I should say I went to
York LA Arizona which you guys have a
lot to do with what gave me the
confidence to do that so Oh ma'am I
don't want her to think that because
she's probably thinking that she's a bad
person
right now where am I willing to leave
this guy behind because I don't like the
snow but she also sounded in Phatak that
it's probably not just the snow and also
seasonal depression is real I used to
get very depressed in the winter / New
York and and I also I'm in a situation
now man where I just met this girl who's
coming to Arizona with me and without
hesitation like we fell in love we gave
each other confidence we built each
other up and she quit her job and she
told her parents she's moving to Arizona
with this guy she just met I flew down
I met her parents it's the the best best
relationship I've ever been in and we're
doing this dramatic move together you
know if it would be one thing if he you
know his job if he's a snow shovel er in
Utah and like that's his passion and and
she's taking him away from that but I
don't know man I mean if he knows that
it is affecting your mental health and
there's nothing you know maybe his
family's there we don't know right but
if there's nothing point it would be
cool if he was supportive or if he
doesn't like Phoenix which by the way I
don't like Phoenix and I'm moving to
Arizona check out other places in
Arizona cuz they're dope er quieter
places that are still an hour two hours
away from you're gonna you're gonna
Tucson right yeah yeah - sounds great
man it's incredible I love this it's
like pre South by Southwest Austin
everyone's just like friendly when they
were like oh this is the bar district I
don't drink so I was like oh I don't
want to check that out but they were
like 18 bookstores so like on the like
party blog yeah like made for me and
it's an hour and a half outside of
Phoenix so when my friends and bands are
playing in Phoenix you can just drive up
so maybe that's the solution but I would
talk to him be super open tell him why
it's important to you don't do that
thing couples do sometimes where you
just want them to kind of read your mind
where you're like we should move too we
should move to Phoenix and he's like I
don't really like Phoenix like why don't
you support me it's because you're not
telling them how important it is to you
and then take it from there that's kind
of my first yeah no I think I definitely
would like to know more information
about the relationship because I agree
there was some hesitation in her voice
with the relationship in general and
though in the moving to Phoenix is it
seems like a symptom of something maybe
more that's going on yeah but yeah I
totally agree like my biggest
recommendation would be like yes just
echo what you said like really get clear
with him
hey I need this to happen in my life in
order for me to be happy like I want you
to be happy I know you want me to be
happy so I'm gonna need some type of
support so if it's not Tucson Arizona if
it's if it's not you know Flagstaff
that's this place in Arizona right yep
yep yeah like you know this ask him if
there is some warm weather state that he
would be willing to consider I mean this
is where the common ground comes in
right yeah for me and I know when we
were living in in Missoula mhm
I was done I was also I was a lot like
Morgan I was so done with the snow like
I I spent the first like 36 plus years
of my life committed to winter yeah
growing up in Dayton Ohio right and the
snow there by the way the crazy humid
summers there and I really like date I
like everything about Dayton except the
weather yeah and leaving there we went
to Missoula we're actually only we're
supposed to be in Montana for four
months but we both met our significant
others there ended up being much longer
but in order to leave because there are
complications right like you said there
might be family there might be jobs
there might be circumstances that tether
you to a place or route to a ploy your
case beck's had a kid there yeah yeah
and it's when I met back so she she had
ella ella was one when i met back and
and so you have to take all of these
things into consideration and then the
question is okay I can't do it right now
this isn't about like well we need to
pack up everything immediately and run
away because you don't want to run away
from the place you're at you want to be
running to the place you're going it yes
you want to be excited about it first of
all Phoenix is - like the reason I think
there's problem with the relationship is
Phoenix is like too shady to throw away
a good relationship you know the only
one if she was going to like Maui or
something like that but if she's just
like it's between my husband and Des
Moines be like it's probably your
husband dude but yeah I'll be clear real
quick I would much rather live in Des
Moines or Phoenix than Maui personally
I'm sorry to all the Des Moines and I
told you I would be apologizing five
minutes into this podcast but I we are
so excited
so my girlfriend and I were literally
like we should think about moving out of
LA next year and then we just kept
getting more excited
like we should go when our leases up in
August and then we were like then we
went to Tucson and we were like we
should go in July and pay double rent
which is what we're doing and then it
got to the point where we were like
what's the earliest we can move in and
we're gonna like pay an extra week to
leave the last week of June right
because we're excited and you want to be
with someone where the last panel of
Calvin and Hobbes is like my favorite
piece of literature where it's
essentially like let's go on an
adventure together and and that's what
you want in a partner and like I said
maybe it's not Phoenix if you just need
to get away from the snow it's not
Phoenix it doesn't have to be feet right
give me so many other places but
definitely think about the relationship
and don't stay in a resentful
relationship it's so dangerous you know
yeah you don't you want to end up in a
place where you're not resenting the
other person and and the same is also
true for your boyfriend Morgan you don't
want to drag him to Phoenix right and
now he's going to resent the
relationship because that puts you in an
odd predicament where you you feel now
obligated to sort of pacify or make up
for it in some way I love the idea jaimé
of adventure and finding someone that
you can adventure with and realizing
that each chapter is just that you don't
you want to leave Salt Lake City for you
right now which is definitely one of my
top five favorite cities I I really like
Salt Lake City in your talk about going
to another place Tucson is top three
favorite cities for me I really enjoy
both places but there's a reason that
you want to leave there's a reason that
you that you want to go right now but
also realize that in dragging him to
another state man you can create this
this dissident that will have ripple
effects from here on out and so you
better have a plan in place yeah and
last thing for me which is it would be
better to go on an adventure to discover
yourself in a city that you've fallen in
love with like Phoenix then to have a
mediocre relationship in a new city to
try to save that relationship right if
you think this is gonna save your
relationship no it's it's just gonna be
a little
when you fight as opposed to it is
equally an adventure to go to rediscover
who you are to find the things you love
to start again in a new city you know I
know even if me and my girlfriend broke
up in Tucson both of our lives are
better for this adventure she got to
leave this nine-to-five that she never
thought she could get out of she has
this new confidence and realizes like
she's artistic like I get to create not
because I'm in front of a bunch of
industry in Los Angeles or because I
want to get onto TV but because I love
the art of stand-up comedy and I get to
be in nature instead of being in New
York City or Los Angeles like both of us
are gonna come out no matter what
happens I hope we get married I hope we
have a family but we're also entering
into a situation where no matter what
both of us are we're moving forward like
you talked about like I said earlier
that this is a chapter and breakups
aren't necessarily a bad thing we did a
whole podcast episode with Nate Greene
about break down and and he just got out
of this 10-year relationship and and
what you learn from that is you can
appreciate those months days years
whatever together and you can move on
from the thing you can graduate from a
relationship and be a better person
because of it and also be a better
partner for future partners as a result
of breakups aren't inherently a bad
thing in our culture we've treated them
that way oh yeah we say well I we got
into one fight and now I hate you and
it's retroactive to everything that
we've ever done and I want to pretend
this relationship never happened
yeah what a terrible way to look at it I
was like I gave you notes on my divorce
I have you just read like the press
blurb of my marriage yeah yeah that's
what happened where I'm Jay you have 10
12 years together and suddenly it's like
you like we hate each other now like
that's garbage like maybe we got into a
fight maybe like we definitely weren't
right for each other maybe whatever but
like it's a bummer to not be able to go
back and appreciate like the good stuff
that happened because good stuffs always
happen the opposite of nostalgia because
nostalgia like paints everything with
rose-colored glasses like everything was
great about I miss it I want to go back
but you don't think about like oh yeah
there was a lot of pain and
and discomfort or whatever and so the
opposite of nostalgia would be like
everything was terrible nothing was good
about this what's a defense mechanism
like she'll do that with if she moves
out of Salt Lake which I really hope you
do she'll do I did that with New York
until I went back I literally went back
to visit New York three months ago and I
was like why didn't I one say the city's
incredible this is like an amazing I'm
like looking at buildings I lived there
for like my whole life and I'm just
suddenly like juices magic I'm walking
through New York I went to Times Square
which I always avoid it when I live
there and it's because if you ask me
what I hated about New York five years
ago I would have said oh it's too
crowded everyone's mean blah blah blah
the real answer is my ex-wife my
ex-girlfriend I felt like a failure I
dropped the ball like with comedy like I
ruined this friendship
it was just personal like psychological
residues what my therapist calls it yeah
and I do the same thing with comedy like
when I quit comedy before I want that
before I came back to it instead of just
being like man I really appreciate
comedy as an art I was like [ __ ] comedy
[ __ ] comedians like you know when Robin
died like he was one of my best friends
on my comedy like took Robin Williams
like and I just hated it and only
recently recently have I started
rewatching stand-up but I'm like no I
love stand-up I felt like a failure so I
just wanted to burn everything down
behind me and the only way to grow is to
learn from everything behind you and
then again use that to propel you
forward yeah I like what you did with
Becks Josh like when you kind of decided
you were like gonna graduate from
Missoula you didn't give her an
ultimatum like I'm leaving next week and
you can either come with me or not I
mean it was like right and you
compromise because if it was up to you
and if it was just you you probably
would have left it that week when media
yeah right well I actually had a lease
in my inbox on our first day so I was
ready to come and I I actually did call
the landlord and I said hey look some
things have changed I'm gonna stick
around in Missoula for a little bit
really sorry like I had a place to live
and everything in LA the week that I met
Beck's but I'm like there's something
here that's over me like that let me
figure this out but to your point Ryan
yeah I I didn't just say well I'm gonna
move and you need to come too it's like
hey this is something that's important
to me is there a way that we can figure
this out together
and knowing that it wasn't going to be
easy there are all these other
complications that routed her to
Missoula but we had to find a way to
make it work it took an additional what
two and a half years to make that work
before we were able to to exit so I had
to deal with the snow and the long
winter is a little bit longer but was
she worth it yes yes and Morgan is is
your boyfriend worth it and only you can
determine that yeah I mean really what
what I think that story says is like
Morgan if you want your boyfriend to
bend a little bit like you're gonna have
to also bend a little bit like you how
long did it
it was a year it wasn't in a year after
you kind of like when he had that lease
in your inbox from that day it was two
and a half years so you stayed in
Missoula for two and a half years two
and now but that was your compromise
just so she doesn't get scared by what
you're saying I think she sounds like
she needs to go now but I think what
you're saying is look for that
compromise like it doesn't mean you have
to stay another winter if you mentally
can't take another winter of course but
like she sounds like she does what I do
where she went to a place and was
suddenly like this is the place that's
gonna solve all my problems like oh my
god and then she looks and the boyfriend
isn't as excited and she just feels like
a stab to the heart where it's like
now's the time but you still got a
couple months before winter like hey
let's visit some other places let's you
know do this so maybe you're not stuck
there for two and a half years but you
know if you could do two and a half
years she can visit a couple other six
years yeah you're probably one
conversation away from solving this now
solving it can mean one of two different
direction yes right but you're probably
one important difficult conversation
away from solving this Morgan I'd love
to give you a copy of our book
minimalism it's the first book Ryan and
I ever wrote but it's about the five
foundational values in our lives and
there's one there well there's one
chapter and they're about relationships
and the nuances of relationships so get
the [ __ ] out of Salt Lake City
hey man you told jazz are their
basketball team anyway so Sean if you
could reach out to Morgan and give her
the audio book version of minimalism if
you it's minimal some live a meaningful
life is the full title but if you like
our podcast you will enjoy the audiobook
version of minimalism or if you want the
book book or the e-book we'll be happy
to send
to you as well Ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it it's time for
our lightning round where we answer
questions from social media indeed we do
we are at the minimalists on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram Instagram and
Jamie Keil steen is at Jamie kill Steen
on Twitter I think @v Jamie kills teen
on Instagram yes follow me and validate
what's funny I heard you talking about
the validation on Twitter how you're
constantly refreshing ah and it's like I
get caught in that sometimes - Matt like
I had made this comment on like
yesterday it happened I was responding
to something that
Ono's totally the comedian's slipping my
mind but anyway he said something about
Jamie yeah that's the other hilarious
Canadian no I said he said something
about Jean Schwartz now people in jean
shorts are like bound to walk slow and I
was like yeah because like they can't
help but strut with such fashion or
something and I started getting started
getting all these likes and I found
myself refreshingly holy get this hour
how many more like sighs oh and by the
way that you know to tie it to what Josh
was saying in the beginning of the
episode that's why that's one of the
main reasons we are screaming at people
with different political points of views
on Twitter I was doing that when I was
miserable and when I was in a
relationship that was failing and when I
was in a city that I didn't like is I
would wake up every day the more if you
tweet if you got home and you tweet like
I really loved the trailer for Lion King
no one gives a [ __ ] except for its gonna
be like lion Kings problematic like I
don't know why but if you tweet hatred
or vitriol or if you attack someone or
if you attack you know like I'm still
pretty liberal but if I attack someone
who I don't think is as liberal and then
it's infighting or you go to like shame
someone that's when your likes and
favorites start to bounce up so that's
what got me addicted to it and I think
that's why all we're doing is calling
each other Marxists and Nazis because
that's what gets the validation that's
what gets your tribe to kind of team up
and start retweeting and start favoring
so now you have this adrenaline if I'm
in a political battle but you're also
getting the dopamine hits from the
Refresh dude I've been recently for some
reason these stories have been popping
up on my YouTube feed so I know there's
an algorithm there's something I'm
looking at that's suggesting these
videos but it's these lake
self-sabotaging stories of these social
media or YouTube influencers who had it
all go to their head so then they
started like just saying crazies like
this one guy was like I am the
Antichrist like Busey too but yeah I'm
like 10 million followers and like how
to break an Internet breakdown right so
I mean but that's but that is exactly
one of the stories that pops up in my
feet I mean I haven't heard of
fouseytube specifically but but that arc
is like a very common thing where you
because you want the validation and you
get so hooked on the dopamine that's it
makes it truly makes you have a mental
breakdown or changes your mentality and
you don't need friends in real life
because you have them online because you
like them not just friends but now all
celebrities are retweeting me when I
call this politician an [ __ ] or
whatever and that's a much bigger deal
so then you start to take down your
contact with people on the outside and
your real relationships I've said this
before but I would literally someone
could be like I was like you know the
term virtue signaling is used by a lot
of extremists but it was what I was
doing where someone could be like hey
Jaime your mom's on the phone and he's
to talk to you and I would be like tell
her I can't talk I'm tweeting about
feminism like I was ignoring people in
my real life to just put out this image
of being this like amazing guy online
and it becomes addicting and I really do
think that is a huge part of why we're
all screaming at each other on the
Internet yeah that's a loose lip I just
remember the comedian was Bill burr it
was something about okay anyway all
right so she we had some funny things
about our documentary did he yeah what'd
he say yeah it's good of the making
minimalism video on our YouTube channel
yeah he he was talking about I get it
get rid of your stuff you'd be happy
like you know oh yeah it's what I've had
people come up and say that our events
were they're like are you really just
saying like focus on what's important to
you and get rid of your stuff and not
focus on things I'm like yeah they were
like well you know what's up with this
event I'm like you can't really just
tweet that and add value to that's
actually why I really liked Jamie's
podcast is because he creates nuance
it's not like it's he does a podcast for
the tribalist I think that's how you
identify yeah that's one of the ways and
so like he is like center-left we used
to be really far left and realized like
the the wrongness of his ways but you
don't you don't correct that by swinging
all the way to the right which was
tempting by the way like when I lost a
lot of the far left audience you know I
literally had a book deal offer when I
lied I lost all my money and I was
sleeping on a couch and I had a book
deal offer to be that guy that's like
why I left the left and the right is
right and I'd have my own Fox News
special and it would be great and I
spent nights on YouTube being like I
maybe I'll like like this Ben Shapiro
guy oh my god no not really
and but but you also recognize that you
can agree with some of the things he
says dismissing him exactly and that's
what I'm trying to do there are so many
issues that if we actually talk to each
other even the most contentious
political issues you will find things
you agree on and I have just lived a
better life you know people say if you
talk to the other side you're like
selling out but I am an aren't you gonna
lead a better more fulfilling life not
thinking that we're like surrounded by
Nazis if we're not surrounded by Nazis I
mean my I went to Texas to meet my
girlfriend's parents the other week and
they are conservative worked in oil
crude everything that the old Jamie who
interviewed Noam Chomsky three times
would have been like we're throwing down
you know I'm gonna bring my picket sign
to dinner but oh all I cared about this
time I didn't care about their politics
all I cared about is that my girlfriend
loves them more than life itself and
then they love and support her no matter
what she's doing it's like oh my god I
can find common ground with people who
have different beliefs yeah and by the
way when we agreed on the fact that hey
we all love Emma when that was the
agreement we came up with we talked
about guns we talked about religion we
talked about gay rights we talked about
everything you're not supposed to talk
about at the dinner table let alone the
dinner table on day one of you meeting
your girlfriend's parents when you look
like I do when covered in tattoos I'm
already I'm like starting at a bit of a
downfall and the mom was texting me I
love you within two days because we
connected that hard on those really hard
issues because we both accepted that we
have the same values and as long as you
have the same values now
we can talk about that we disagree on
how to get to those values but instead
of being like oh you don't believe in
universal healthcare you want kids to
die or you're not pro-choice like you
hate women like but finding out like why
do you believe these things then you can
actually come up with solutions let's
try to answer these questions and less
than hundred forty characters Christ
Shawn puts the are quotes in the show
notes you can also find them at minimal
Maxim's com he actually just mix it
something pithy that tweetable we can
reminisce ramble no no don't make it
look pretty great our first question is
from Amanda how can I find common ground
with people who have different beliefs
such as how to raise your kids I'm glad
she didn't use like another belief lake
you know something that was truly
divisive like this is I feel like this
is a very nice leg well we could have a
question about abortion later so we'll
get to that but here's my pithy answer
for you stand your ground even if you
can't find common ground and really what
I'm saying there is is don't compromise
your values you can change your beliefs
beliefs are are malleable and they
should be otherwise it becomes dogma and
that's really dangerous we talked about
that on last week's episode but also
listen to the people who have different
beliefs because they might even change
your mind I'm not talking about a full
180 but they might make you pivot five
degrees and that five degree shift as
Jamie figured out when he was he decided
you know maybe these beliefs
maybe I'm too tethered to them I'm
clinging to them too tightly I don't
need to let go of all of them but I need
to loosen my grip a little bit yeah I am
I don't know how to give a pithy answer
to this so I'll say oh there's no I in
team that's my pity answer my actual
team Jamie Jamie Kelsey podcast yeah I I
was actually I'm excited to answer the
abortion cuz I think there's I think
there's an answer to even the most
controversial yeah we'll get to that but
let's talk about raising kids raising
kids is actually like equally as
personal right like if someone told me
how to raise my kids I would you want to
get very very defensive what I would say
I totally agree with you which is you
can learn from everybody you can learn
from the people you told
disagree with its Bruce Lee be like
water right like the reason Bruce Lee
became one of the best martial artists
is because he didn't stick to just I'm
just gonna be a karate guy or a jujitsu
guy or a Muay Thai guy or a boxing guy
he took the best from each art I think
it was like he said like use what's
useful disregard what's useless or
something like that and he took the best
from each art and this is how we have
modern mixed martial arts as well use
that and threw away the stuff he didn't
like right so there's probably something
you can learn from even the people who
you most vehemently disagree with I'm
raising your kids but like you said I
mean it's your kids you're gonna know as
long as you're not being stubborn and
you're not ignoring that person in the
opinion for something that has to do
with your own ego where you're like
these are my [ __ ] kids and I know how
to raise them if I want to let them sit
in a hot car with the windows up I mean
you know what I mean like well that's
not good but at the same time you know
see if there's anything to learn from it
then you can just kind of move on but if
you have a friend who was constantly
ridiculing you if that's what inspired
her tweet where she has someone or a
relative or a sister or someone who just
every time you see them you know you
really should be doing this with your
kids you really should be doing this
maybe that person is like a shady person
and you don't need to have them and in
your life love them from a distance yeah
and they're projecting their own stuff
on you but if if it's well-intentioned
advice and it's not coming in a passive
aggressive or mean way see if there's
anything to take from it and then be
like thank you for your thank you for
your comments your thoughts and comments
yeah let's move on that's exactly I mean
I mean my short answer is showing
respect is the best way to avoid
confrontation so yeah if someone wants
to give you advice in your kids and you
don't want to hear it that's exactly the
way I just go cool man yeah thank you
thank you for the advice I appreciate it
because that's really what do we want
out of our relationships romantic or
friendships man like we want to show
respect we want to be respected like
that's how you're going to get along
with people even though you have
different beliefs yeah all right our
next question is from Nick Nick why do I
find it so difficult to find common
ground with certain people no matter how
open-minded and consider it I try to be
it feels impossible it's my problem a
lack of willingness to learn something
new is it closed mindedness
well my pithy answer is this
and we can unpack it a little bit
because the question is hey am I being
closed-minded and and I think this is a
spectrum right so an open mind is an
asset a porous mind is a liability like
this glass right here it works really
well because there is a top and I can
sip out of it it was completely closed
it would just be a vessel of trapped
water if there was a hole in the bottom
or on the side or a bunch of holes
throughout then it wouldn't serve any
purpose at all right I think the same is
true with with the open mind
closed-minded thing and Jamie with you
you you you had a relatively closed mind
when you were podcasting before right
and this is something that you've you've
talked about yeah I mean my pity answer
is when God closes a door he opens a
window that's also trademark Jamie Keil
Steen and yeah totally I mean a lot of
times we and we see this on Twitter when
like someone to Twitter by bio is like
contrarian and yours like if that's the
thing I'm gonna own it's like I'm gonna
constantly [ __ ] on your ideas and
disagree it's like are you doing that
for the right reasons right so the
person who wrote in self aware enough to
ask if I'm close-minded great first step
like that person is definitely savable
but you have to have you become addicted
to just being the guy that goes but
actually you know what I mean or like
here's why because that was something
again on the left that happened where
anytime someone liked something you know
you would have to tell them why they're
wrong
or why you know you could literally
tweet like love crazy rich Asians
everyone left crazy rich Asians but me
old Jamie and me friends were like oh so
all raisins are crazy and like what
about like uh what kind of Asians are
they like what are their trans Asians
and you just like find ways just to
attack attack attack attack and be like
I am better than you if that's why
you're constantly disagreeing you
shouldn't ever be having conversations
just to prove you're right I mean that's
the best relationship advice I can give
to if both of your goals are to become
better people and save the relationship
instead of I want to win this fight then
you should be psyched to apologize you
should be psyched to figure out to
realize you're wrong you know I mean
that's what happens now when you're
having these political arguments so many
times you're
actually hearing what the person saying
you're just lock and loading you're
talking point that your team told you
about and a lot of times you don't even
you couldn't even go into depth about
you're talking point you just go I know
when this person says that you know we
should have college for all I'm supposed
to say how do you pay for that but
neither of you are actually looking at
you know maybe the liberal is not
looking at how do we pay for that maybe
the Conservatives not looking at you
know maybe we should have free education
even if we don't know how to do it right
now how can we talk about this how can
we have a conversation so if you were
constantly trying to disagree with
someone to prove that you are smarter or
that you're more well-read or you think
you're gonna like you know help this
poor hapless victim who doesn't know the
that day's talking points from CNN or
from the intercept or from the National
Review or whatever side you're on no
good you should go into conversations
excited to learn excited to change your
mind
excited to evolve we viewed the term
flip flopper is such a negative thing
when in reality to me like changing your
mind is great that's one of like the key
steps to evolution to moving on and yeah
I used to do that all the time because I
assumed to me being liberal was I want
more people to have rights which also
means that I assume that all Republicans
don't and I've had I there's probably
about half of my audience even though
I'm still very liberal who are
conservatives and we got one yesterday a
dude on patreon is giving us $50 a month
which is insane and he wrote I don't
agree with anything you say it was
hysterical his email anything and he
goes and I don't want you to pander to
me no matter how much you pissed me off
I am still gonna give you this money for
at least a year he said which is 500
bucks to listen to someone who
politically enriches you and he goes
because I like the way you're doing it
and I like that you're not name-calling
and I like and so that to me was the
greatest compliment I've ever gotten it
as opposed to the years where I had
people in my own echo chamber being like
I agree with the thing you said so keep
saying it and then I would have to keep
saying it and keep saying it my life is
so much richer reading people I disagree
talking people I disagree with and
sometimes changing my mind and sometimes
being like Oh still disagree but like
you're a dope person let's be friends
you're making room for other people's
mistakes and nuances and I think if we
can do that if we make room that is the
best place to approach any discussion or
place from which we we disagree yeah
definitely my pet the answer is
approaching opinions from multiple sides
makes it easier to respect those we
disagree with and again like people just
want to know that you see where they're
coming from so like if you can take a
moment to put yourself in someone's
shoes and like see why they have that
opposing that complete opposite belief
or that complete opposite value like
that's gonna help you get closer to
having some meaningful conversations
like I'm reading this book right now I
forget the guys name I know his last
name is
eisen-steen but it's called climate
change a news story and like the dude is
he paced approaches it with like hey if
you're a climate denier you're on the
wrong side or if you're a climate change
denier you're on the wrong side if you
use the term climate change denier
you're on the wrong side like he takes
his very Senate approach and what he
does in the book is he goes through all
of the skeptical information when it
comes to climate change he goes through
all the scientific data that supports
you know the climate change with the co2
and and and it's it's a really rich book
on how to look at the environment and
I'll tell you it like it the far left
side when it comes to the environment
like there off a little bit and on the
far right side there off a little bit
and he goes through both sides and that
I think is what what is again is going
to create the meaningful outcome oh dude
check this out so I literally just
talked about this on today's podcast
where I talk to you an old comedian
friend of mine who's conservative and we
stopped talking and Apollo there was
Nick DiPaolo yeah it was Dennis Miller
and we we stopped talking and he gave me
my first stage time in New Jersey so we
have this phone call and I just randomly
DM him and was just like hey man I
probably said some shitty things to you
when I was like a liberal [ __ ] I'm
really sorry and he's like can I call
you and we had the greatest conversation
about comedy about how you know about
censorship nowadays but all this stuff
and we started talking about climate
change and he said he goes I hate the
new green deal if I saw someone on
Twitter say I hate the
Green Deal not only would I assume there
are climate change denier I'd be like oh
this [ __ ] hillbilly who probably
thinks Jesus is gonna fix everything
probably hates aoc because he hates
women and he's got a tiny dick and I
would just be like I'd be such an
[ __ ] right away because I said why he
goes well I read it and I read a bunch
of scientific stuff
scientific papers I read scientific
papers all day long which I would have
had no idea and same thing he said
there's a bunch of stuff that's a little
bit off mm-hmm
with that said he goes I think America
should be the number one the the number
one resource when it comes to
alternative fuel because I want America
to be number one mm-hmm what does a
lefty environmentalist want they want us
to use our resources to come up with
alternative fuel sources so because we
kept the conversation going not only did
I find out okay extreme left's a little
off extreme rights a little off but we
have the same [ __ ] goal yeah right I
don't care if he wants to do it because
he wants an American flag does I [ __ ]
you China we have solar or whatever
don't care right and I want to do it
because I think the world's gonna end
because the climate change right we
won't we want it for different reasons
but just because we kept talking for
five more minutes you and I didn't
assume he was like a sexist Jesus Freak
and he didn't assume I was like a dumb
in a on it okay exactly we have
literally the exact same goal yeah you
found that common ground by just digging
in a little bit deeper trying to see it
from his side making room for nuance
yeah all right it looks like we have a
bunch more questions here today Jamie
and we're gonna answer some of these
here how do you deal with a friend who
says your political beliefs are ruining
the country
how should loved-ones reconcile
conflicting beliefs what's the best way
to discuss life's most controversial
topics like abortion are we talking
about that how do you deal with someone
who annoys you and we've got several
more questions also Jamie you had this
tweet I want to talk to you about this
tweet where you said I was hoping my
fear anxiety and depression would fight
it out and leave me to deal with only
one but they appear to have joined
forces to destroy me
did happen we're going to be talking
about all of that and if you want to
hear all of that you can listen to this
week's maximal episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different much longer
maximal episode on the minimus private
podcast which gives us the private space
we need to talk about topics we don't
usually discuss in public
Plus patreon is the best way for us to
fund this podcast and keep it 100%
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the middle most private podcast on
patreon you'll also receive a personal
link so that our maximal episodes play
in your favorite podcast app find all
the details and all the good stuff over
at the minimalists comm slash support
Ryan what else you got for us this week
man as always being informed is more
important than ever these days I mean
you know talking about how we put
ourselves in these bubbles in fact we
did a podcast a while back about being
in our own bubble in Missoula this
liberal haven in Montana yeah and it's
like when I did that you know Trump gets
elected and I was totally aloof to like
what was going on outside of my bubble
here I was in Park Slope Brooklyn right
like wait what just happened yeah but
you know here's the thing though is like
that experience helped me to appreciate
that I need to read more and get
informed to look at all sides so I'm not
stuck in this bubble also here I've got
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners check them out hi I'm
grace from the Bay Area and I just
wanted to make a comment on your
sustainable living episode so I started
my minimalism sustainability journey a
year ago as a sophomore in high school
and recently I've actually realized that
making my own beauty products has made a
positive impact on my life and my
self-care routine everything is natural
and it also builds a nice relationship
because it takes more time and you'll
use less products that are maybe not
useful in your routine hi my name is
Lori
I'm from the Chicago area I wasn't able
to come to the event in Chicago but I
did listen to the podcast of it and I
come from a long line of hoarders even
though I don't struggle with
accumulating stuff myself and I wanted
to talk to
the woman who had said she was having
trouble getting rid of things because
she didn't have a car
one thing I've noticed is that many
times people who struggle with too many
possessions have plans specific plans
for those items you know you might hear
someone say I can't get rid of those
doilies because I'm giving them to Aunt
Sally or you know I'm keeping the paper
towel tubes because I'm going to bring
them to the local preschool for crafts
but that day never comes and you just
keep holding on to it a side note here
is that we often make plans for our
thing not just to hold on to them longer
but because we attribute more value to
those items than they actually have but
that would be a whole other conference
so for people who struggle with stuff I
just recommend being really honest with
yourself about the plans you have for
those items they may found altruistic
but it may just be like a veiled way of
excusing yourself to continue to keep
those items so I recommend just pack it
all up donate it all to Goodwill or
Salvation Army or have somebody come and
pick it up and whoever's meant to have
those items will find them and you can
just let go of that responsibility of
feeling like you need to find the
perfect home for it and then you won't
be able to use logistics or lack of time
as an excuse to hold on to things all
right so thanks again to Jamie Keil
Steen for joining us today Jamie I want
to encourage folks listen to your daily
podcast the Jack Hillston show yep Jamie
Coulson podcast iTunes stitcher Spotify
for free we're also at patreon if you
guys liked what I said at all and we
also talked about like mental health and
stuff like that but the podcast is daily
it's short it's covering stories the way
I talked about them today and you'll
definitely hear it on your guys patreon
episode we talked about the more
controversial issues it would be a lot
easier every time I've asked like my
famous friends how do you make more
money get more listeners they're like
start fights and literally they've told
me like start fights on Twitter everyone
will want to back you up if I was a
screaming lefty or a screaming
conservative who used to be a lefty it
is a lot easier to make money that way
especially under Trump especially being
so divided as we
are when I told my agent I want to do a
podcast about nuance and conversation he
essentially looked to me like go [ __ ]
yourself
but I think it's really important and
the people who have found the podcast
like I said conservatives write in all
the time but we also have like
eighteen-year-old
LGBT punk kids who listen to the show
and they're talking to each other and
they're becoming friends and it's a
really cool community that like
literally our fans have helped other
fans like who have been suicidal like
we're building something cool that's not
as sexy to pitch as screaming and
yelling and I love your show and what
you guys stand for and your show
literally saved my life when it comes to
the move the when it comes to Ed when it
came to a lot of stuff that I was doing
incorrectly in my life and so I think a
lot of your audience will like it I hope
they check it out or at least say hey to
me and I just yeah I love what you guys
do so much and appreciate this
definitely appreciate you man yeah love
you brother
right here right now this is where we
talk about one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalist we just put
this essay out on our website called how
much is enough and this is a question
that Ryan and I have been trying to
tackle over the last month or two months
three months we've seen a significant
growth on on our patreon side and you
and I've actually had conversations
about enough and like what a Minimum
Viable audience is I'm just gonna read
an excerpt from this but you can find it
at the minimalists comm slash enough how
much is enough without asking this
question we blindly pursue excess we
have been acculturated to act
rapaciously acquire consume indulge more
more more how much is enough without an
answer we don't know how to proceed
because we don't know when to stop
mindless desire takes us by the hand of
course enough is different for each of
us enough changes as our needs and
circumstances change you're enough may
include a sofa a coffee table and TV a
dining table that seats six a
three-bedroom home a two-car garage a
backyard trampoline or that might be too
much enough changes over time yesterday
is enough
maybe too much today how much is enough
less than enough is depriving more than
enough is indulging enough is the sweet
spot in the middle the place where
intentionality intersects with
contentment where left where lust
doesn't get in the way of creating
something meaningful
the essay goes on to talk about how Ryan
and I recently capped our patreon
audience at six thousand people so we're
done at six thousand we're now at six
thousand yet but we've seen it over the
last three or four months just double in
size and what we're realizing is like
okay we're not just trying to grow for
the sake of growing Seth Godin has this
thing which I sent to you about the
Minimum Viable audience and in Kevin
Kelley has this thing about the thousand
true fans and what we're realizing is
this podcast is free and accessible and
advertisement free to anyone who wants
to listen to it but there's some times
we want to go deeper and talk about
things that we don't normally talk about
in public and so we want to cap that
because I don't want that to continue to
necessarily grow but I also I want it to
be a group of people who understand us
where we feel the freedom to not be
judged or criticized unnecessarily now
you can give us feedback and some cool
we appreciate the feedback
right and so we figure out what enough
is for us just like when we started
dealing with consumerism in our lives we
figured out what was enough stuff and
that enough has changed over time now I
have a family enough is different now I
live in California
enough is different from me and so that
continues to change and for me and Ryan
we figure it out like yeah we could rock
it past six thousand people but could is
not a good reason to do anything and so
you can check that out the minimalists
comm slash enough if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast leave us a voicemail for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
or send a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm you can comment on this
episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalists if you want our show notes
in your inbox sign up for our e-mail
list over at the minimalists comm and
you'll also receive our simple Sunday
emails each week for added value this
week this is like perfectly on topic I
think since we're talking about finding
common ground
and being triggered by other people on
social media right I was that person
sorry there's there's a song that I'm
although I'm being triggered by people
we love it's so easy to be triggered by
those people right well there's this
song with it like this beautiful melody
that creates this strange but beautiful
dissonance with the anger that are in
the lyrics
there's a singer janay a ICO I'm not
sure familiar with this the song called
triggered and there's it's a beautiful
song but when you listen to lyrics
you're like oh there is this dissonance
here and I think that that in a way that
that's that's how all relationships work
they're difficult they're beautiful
they're filled with emotion and of
course we get to choose what emotions we
let in ultimately or what emotions we we
let linger amen so let's listen the
triggered by janae a ICO and if you
leave here today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time and minimus